des cendre revient
plus la même
je ne
claude gauthier noël sans vie et qui dit
noël dit la chanson marie noëlle qui a
55 ans cette année vous avez signé le
texte
robert charlebois signe la musique et
vous avez chacun votre version de cette
chanson là qu'elle est la petite
histoire derrière cette grande chanson 1
on est en 1964 j'ai eu la curiosité de
demander à charles boire trop et qui dit
j'écris des chansons à bon je me sens
entendre via la maison un moment donné
ce qui le fait il est arrivé un matin de
décembre
il neigeait des flocons gros comme ça
robert dit c est ici groupe des balles
de golf
on s'est émerveillé devant ça et puis il
y avait une musique de commencer il joue
ça je dis oh là là tu as un peu apte à
moi et je suis parti avec 15 décembre
vieux pendant le jeu ils disent et c'est
inélégant ça je dis oui c'est un clin
d'oeil on pourrait dire quand il neige
quand la neige quand il neige neige mais
j'ai voulu faire un clin d'oeil à émile
nelligan
non
c'est
je joue et alors là et dans quelques
petites bouteilles
on a écrit marie noëlle
aux enfants de demain
je fais ce genre d'entrevue pour les
générations à venir votre nouvel album
s'intitule justement aux enfants de
demain j'espère que redire en france que
les lycéens de fautes gotti qui vous
même vous êtes l'enfant spirituel de
félix leclerc
quand félicitèrent est arrivé ça mau
prix à l'âme pour juste au bout des
doigts comme ça ça aussi rentrer en moi
notre sentier pour les who is who on
connaît toutes les chansons de félix le
train une heure qu'ils pensaient à 500
pieds derrière la maison qui faisait
vibrer maison chaque fois qu'ils passent
et quand ils en parlaient je savais de
quoi il parlait aussi récemment un prix
ça imprégné en moi et beaucoup beaucoup
de choses pourquoi j'ai écrit des
chansons dans ma vie ben ça part de là
j'ai fait le plus beau voyage qui ont
goûté cette année on a souligné les 50
ans de la crise d'octobre
c'est un moment important je même que ça
vous a replongé dans certains dans un
certains souvenirs parce que vous l'avez
vécu des positions débarquer chez vous
mais ça vous a inspiré une chanson le
plus beau voyage aussi c'est que moi
aussi en 1977 empêché de faire du show
où j'étais visiter à la maison tard
trois constats d'être aux gendarmes de
la grc mitraillette coupé sous le
manteau là à 11h30 de soi au retour de
cinéma et puis ils ont cogné cogner bing
bang bang bang j'étais obligé d'ouvrir
en arrière en avant et au jeudi fait pas
de bruit s'il vous plaît j'ai un enfant
qui dort ouais ok on va essayer il
faisait quand même pas mal de bruit j'ai
dit pourquoi vous êtes si jeune si
jacques aux grands 6 pieds que j'ai
écrit l'onuci qui oui mais moi ça m'a
marqué ça d'une façon fort sens j'aurais
aimé aller rejoindre médium qui était
emprisonné michel chartrand
gérald godin pauline julien et est doté
de otero parce qu'elle 450 arrestations
arbitraires sans mandat sans rien en mai
film québécois préféré c'est sans aucun
doute les ordres de michel brault qui
parle justement de la crise d'octobre
quels souvenirs gardez-vous de ce
tournage de ce film est là et de
l'importance de ce fait ce film là on a
marqué beaucoup c'est évident et quand
je suis dans ce rôle là je pense à tout
ça je pense à tous ces gens qui sont ici
comment dire c'était facile pour moi de
rentrer dans ce personnage
d'abord c'est un personnage de musiciens
qui travaillent pas le jour puis sa
femme travaille ici pensons que du bébé
donc jamais je venais de connaissent
avec un jeune enfant aussi un peu mais
le soleil
où ira demain
vous avez 81 ans vous avez vécu la
révolution trac elle maintenant selon
vous quel genre de révolution safran
pour les plus jeunes
mon dieu c'est vrai j'ai bien peur j'ai
bien peur j'entends souvent quand je
pense que le français pour mourir un
jour au québec
vous le croyez à moins à moins qu on se
lève tous debout demain matin pour dire
non ils vont pas mourir
claude guth si joyeuse fête merci
beaucoup pour cet entretien
merci gens l'embrassent tous
virtuellement c'est pas dangereux
je fais le plus beau voyage
dans mon enfance à aujourd'hui
[Musique]